so
if we look at communism and they define
angles and uh
and uh marx say the abolition of
uh uh abolition of property right and
then you
have the at the end of the book forcible
overthrows of all existing social
condition okay right it's fine so we
have those two definitions then what how
would you define
socialism yeah and
lenin wrote in the state and revolution
which is this kind of
opus and he wrote that in 1917
couldn't finish writing it because
because the revolution overtook them
but he wrote in there he said as mark
said
in in communism socialism is just the
final transitionary step before
communism
so you know the it it's one phase that
leads to a higher phase
marion smith who was the executive
director of victims of communist
memorial foundation
says well uh just as religious believers
christians and jews aspire to heaven the
socialist aspires to communism
right communism is the sort of new
jerusalem you know that's
that's the that's the utopia that's
that's the heaven on earth
so in true marxist leninist theory
socialism is the final transitionary
step to communism
now that said you'll run into all sorts
of socialists today who say well
but that's not the kind of socialist
that i am right
i don't support communism i wouldn't go
that far
i support single-payer health care i
support maybe government taking over
the energy sector i support this and
well all right fine but if you type in
at google or merriam-webster
socialism what will pop up is socialism
common ownership of the means of
production
so you know historically socialism
that's what it is
ussr union of soviet socialist republics
it's the final transitionary step to
communism
it it makes you it makes you wonder so
so
i'm a math guy i'm a numbers guy because
it makes sense to me and it's absolute
right so if i look at communism
communism if i go on one side 100 to me
is communism
okay so is there a way to come up with a
number that tells us where socialism is
when it comes down to taxes
has that study been done because arthur
laffer said yes around 33 and a half 34
and a half percent and
you know uh you've seen a lot of
different studies but is there a
way to quantify what socialism is since
we know how to quantify
communism that's a great question i love
that and
in my comparative politics course at
grove city college every fall
we use the heritage foundation's index
of economic freedom
they rank countries from number one to
about number 170
most economically free to least
economically free
and the top two have been hong kong and
singapore
pretty much ever since they started
doing this study in the 1990s
and then you have new zealand maybe
ireland
maybe the uk maybe the united states
were around the top ten
and then china i think is usually around
like 100 120.
um spain italy france you know who knows
30s 70s they're all over the place but
at the very end
the very end is always north korea and
cuba cuba
yeah so in a way i that that guide i
find
very very useful as as kind of
a ranking system and a country there
that would be
around 150 venezuela's down to the
bottom now too
zimbabwe is down at the bottom so i'd
say when you're in that
range of like the bottom 10 percent
bottom 20
150 to 170 you're kind of in you know
collectivism
socialism you know that
you're you're in that territory got it
but there's never been a number that
they've put to it meaning give tax if
you pay more than 60
taxes it's socialism if you're paying
more than 30 taxes at socialism what
that that's what i'm looking for yeah
that's a good question yeah
and to do it through tax rates to truly
have
abolition of private property by the way
the top three
in marx and ingles 10 point plan
abolition of property and land
graduated or progressive income tax oh
and my favorite
abolition of all right of inheritance
all right so abolition of all right of
inheritance would technically mean
right for you and i who are practical
guys and trying to figure out what these
guys are saying that would have to be
like 100
um inheritance tax right death tax
so if you have a 100 tax on inheritance
is the only way you're going to abolish
all right of inheritance that would be
communism
um i know if you have a 50 tax rate on
inheritance
i'd like to call that socialist i think
it's pretty damned outrageous
um 70 percent would be outraged tax
rates uh in the united states we
introduced the federal income tax in
1913 permanent federal income tax it was
a few percentage points
by 1921 under woodrow wilson it was 73
percent
fdr took it up to 94
on income over 100 000 and fdr if you
read bert folsom's book fdr goes to war
fdr in the 1940s wanted a 99.5
tax rate on incomes over 100 000
now i would call that pretty close to
communism he might not be quoting marks
when he's doing it
but i'd have to say that that would be
pretty close a 99.5
tax rate on income over a hundred
thousand dollars
that's like almost complete confiscation
and redistribution of wealth
at that point but to pick a hard number
marx and ingles never gave one
and this is infuriating for practical
minded business people
they also they would say well you know
at this point
you've left capitalism and then
socialism and then kaplan
i want to know at which point in the
process we're there
right i want to know who's the vanguard
who's a group of leaders that say oh
okay all right okay
we are now comrades from point
b to point c right i can now say that
we've officially entered
communist society none of this is ever
clear
and it has to be decided by dictators
that's what it comes down to
very interesting by the way on the 99.5
i mean
i would i would love to know what's the
right book to read where it's going to
be unbiased and it's going to tell me
what was his motive and taking it to
99.5 like what yeah
it's um it's bert folsom uh fdr
goes to war he wrote it with his wife
anita
he's a hillsdale professor retired
hillsdale what's the book about uh
it's called fdr goes to war i got it so
it's about the 1940s
and um yeah 99.5 right by the way people
thinking
well he must have just wanted it for
wartime no
no no no no no fdr fdr was had jacked
the rate up to 91
the reason ronald reagan left the
democratic party
was um over fdr's tax rates and that's
that's what drove him out of the
democratic party that
probably more than anything else so if
you like this sort of short clip from an
interview i did click over here to watch
the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye
you